Pizza Polizist sebastian hat heute einen
Durchsuchungsbeschluss bei der Bäckerei
Ditsch ich möchte es wirklich nicht
Pizza nennen wir nennen es vielleicht
mal
teigprodukt mit Tomaten und
Käsegeschmack er deckt auf was im
pizzasack steckt
[Musik]
Bongiorno na lust auf eine leckere Pizza
dafür braucht man nur ein paar gute
Zutaten Mehl Tomate Mozzarella Hefe Salz
ein bisschen Olivenöl einen schönen Ofen
am besten mit Holz befeuert Zeit
haben Sie sich schon mal eine Pizza am
Bahnhof geholt mal eben auf die Schnelle
sensorischen ähnliches Vergnügen aber
ganz andere Zutaten
Sebastian liege hat die Zutaten für eine
Industrie Pizza zusammengestellt
10 Schälchen fast alle voller Pulver
[Musik]
Pizza Romantik jetzt vorbei meine
italienische Freunde werden jetzt die
Hände über den Kopf zusammenschlagen
wenn die sehen
nein was macht denn da jetzt für eine
Pizza das sind Originalzutaten keine
Sorge
Mehl ist drin
Pizzateig benötigt klassisch mindestens
24 Stunden zum Reifen dafür bleibt bei
Fast Food keine Zeit Schüler Nase ist
ein Reife Beschleuniger Teig muss Reifen
hiermit kann er sofort verarbeitet
werden
und nicht nur ein Reife Beschleuniger
nein gleich zwei
Enzyme für doppelte Power also Amylase
sorgt auch dafür dass der Teig schneller
reift
ja Zeit kostet Geld aber gelernt
hiermit oxidiert der Teig nicht Natrium
steha-öl zwei laktylant ist ein
Konservierungsstoff außerdem hält er
Wasser im Teig die Pizza trocknet nicht
ein sie wird so länger frisch
nein schön stabiles Fett weil diese
Pizzen liegen in der Auslage manchmal
ein oder zwei Stunden kommt ja immer auf
Verkehr an und die sollen ja nicht
austrocknen die sollen ja noch genauso
saftig schmecken wie gerade frisch aus
dem Ofen und da sind die härtete das
Beste
Fetthärtung ist ein chemischer Prozess
günstige Öle werden dabei in
streichfestes Fett verwandelt
gehärtete Fette geben dem Teig
Stabilität und halten ihn lange frisch
eine pizza-polizei der Welt für
zu dir so müssen so im Stil so alt New
Yorker Mafia Familie sein eh nix Pizza
gehört zu dem Schweizer
valora-konzern einem der größten
systemgastronomieunternehmen in
Deutschland
auch Back-Factory und Backwerk gehören
zum Konzern
jetzt fehlt noch die Marinade so nennt
man klassisch die rote Soße auf der
Pizza der nimmt man sogar Dosentomaten
die sind perfekt am besten
am Fuße des vesus das ist die Pizza Soße
[Musik]
Wasser und Rapsöl bilden die Basis
Sebastian lege gibt Zucker Salz
modifizierte Stärke Zwiebelpulver
Hefeextrakt und Zitronensäure hinzu
ein paar Kräuter soll uns ja zumindest
so vermitteln
Italien
paprikaextrakt liefert die kräftige rote
Farbe frische Tomaten kommen nicht in
die Tomatensoße
frische Tomaten werden viel zu
kompliziert man müsste Wasser
transportieren und und und und und das
Zeugs kannst du sackweise Lagern über
Jahre deswegen extrem praktikabel
ja
ich fühle mich ein bisschen wie die
Ghostbusters
[Musik]
keine Pizza
tomatenpulver erspart der industriezeit
und Geld Sebastian lege mixt aus dem
Pulver gemischt eine stabile Tomatensoße
zack
pizzasoße fertig
[Musik]
schmeckt original eine ditch Pizza
besteht zu 14% aus Pulver Tomatensoße
Teig formen Soße auftragen Belag
verteilen das alles geschieht
vollautomatisch
herzlich willkommen in meiner Pizza
Fabrik
ja wir haben hier mal eine schöne
Produktionsstraße aufgebaut hier nichts
mit Ausrollen von Hand und schön am
Feuer Backen nee nee nee nee hier sind
doch Effizienz getrimmt
Sebastian lege stellt Pizza am Fließband
her
auf den perforierten Teig gibt er die
vorgegebene Menge pulversoße
dann backt er den Rohling an
ich möchte es wirklich nicht Pizza
nennen wir nennen es vielleicht mal
teigprodukt mit Tomaten und
Käsegeschmack
[Musik]
die Teiglinge werden je nach Sorte
belegt mit Käse Paprika Zwiebeln und
Salami nach dem Backen werden sie
schockgefrostet perfekt für Lagerung und
Lieferung in die Filialen
meine Pizza Zunge ist fertig
das ist der letzte Produktionsschritt im
Store und so geht die dann in die Tüte
geworden
pulverpizza als schneller Snack auf die
Hand italienisches Vorbild günstig von
der Industrie optimiert
darf man das noch Pizza nennen super
einfaches Tiefkühlprodukt und extrem
effizient produziert komm kartonweise
ins Tor an wird nur noch durch den Ofen
gejagt und verkauft
[Musik]
die fertige Pizza trocknet in der
Auslage auch nach Stunden nicht aus
eine Rezeptur mit Konservierungsstoffen
und gehärteten Fetten macht es möglich
[Musik]
das spart Zutaten Zeit und Personal wir
haben hier viele Zusatzstoffe die
einerseits eine lange Haltbarkeit
garantieren aber auch viel Wasserbindung
ermöglichen das heißt ich kann Wasser
für teuer Geld verkaufen und
gleichzeitig sind auch wirklich
minderwertige Zutaten enthalten als
Verbraucher bekomme ich sogar mit einer
Tiefkühlpizza hochwertigere Zutaten als
mit so einem pizzaschneck
die Salami Pizza wird für 1,90 €
pro 100 g verkauft
eine Tiefkühl Salami Pizza von Wagner
hingegen kostet nur 79 Cent pro 100
Gramm
der Blick auf die Zutatenliste verrät
Wagner setzt echte geschälte Tomaten ein
Ditsch nur Pulver